after two years running the world from
home the political and business elite is
back in the swiss alps this week a
spring world economic forum without the
snow but plenty to discuss the war in
ukraine top of the agenda with president
zielenski addressing the meeting by
video link and mps and ministers from
kiev here in person
with a clear message the west must do
more to stand up to moscow if you are
paying two russian companies for their
oil for their gas you are giving them
resources to continue
uh destructing our towns our villages
killing our children killing raping our
women elderly toddlers babies and uh and
destroying the country but there'll be
no russians the oligarchs who used to
throw the most opulent parties are
banned and there's very little british
presence chancellor rishi sunak is
staying away and so is the business
secretary
despite or perhaps because of the rare
concentration of wealth and power that
can make davos look like a party to
which only the super rich are invited
i think we all know that we're in the
middle of a very difficult global
context there are a lot of crises afoot
there is of course the geopolitical
conflict
there is the ongoing effects of the
pandemic and all of this every single
day is affecting people's lives and that
is exactly why we need to bring those
that have the ability to support those
that are suffering from this current
moment together and start rebuilding
towards a new era of cooperation
the big global brands are here to show
their wares in a rarified environment
that celebrates the virtues of liberal
capitalism
with few dissenting voices
the world economic forum says it wants
to improve the world through responsible
capitalism and with a war in europe and
an economic and potentially a food
crisis they've got plenty to work on
they might also consider here how things
have gone so badly wrong
a united stand against russian
aggression may be the truest measure of
whether davos's return makes a
difference
paul kelso sky news in davos